now then about seven out of ten people
who had taken to hospital with curvy 19
have not fully recovered after five
months according to recently published
research
now there are many more who are not
admitted to hospital but also
suffer symptoms of long coverage such as
muscle pain fatigue
breathlessness or brain fog for a
considerable time well i'm joined now
by the actor emma sams who is suffering
from
long covert uh very good to talk to you
amazon i don't know tell us emma
i understand you contracted cover you
think almost exactly a year ago on the
way back from
america did you end up in hospital
i didn't i i i was sent to hospital but
i wasn't
admitted which was obviously a fantastic
um but i had to sort of
do as best as i could at home after that
and i was
as one would imagine anticipating that
i would feel better um very soon
um and was just you know sort of willing
myself to get through
the two weeks we thought um and then
actually i just never got better did you
have
a respite or anything like that and it
it came back or have you just been
feeling
terrible for these 12 months
well it isn't it isn't linear it does go
up and down and you have good days and
bad days
and that confuses people around you and
it confuses me too sometimes
um so yes the the the trick is is not
to push yourself too hard on the good
days because you think oh finally i can
do that like i bought a bike ages ago
and dying to get out on it
and um i i've stopped myself because you
just paid the consequences all the more
the next day
so it's very it's very odd
psychologically and what are the
symptoms i mean you described that
the tiredness there well the exhaustion
i should say
what else well for me
and and everybody has different symptoms
which is making it very
uh tricky for for the for the doctors of
course but
for me it's as you can hear it's
shortness of breath um
i have uh chest pain um and the
amazing fatigue that i've never known
anything like that before
even when i had two little babies up at
night um
nothing even close so
it's um it's also i've got the sort of
standard
not being able to smell much at all or
taste anything
i sometimes have some weird phantom
smells like i keep smelling um
diesel fumes um at the moment that's the
latest thing
it's just a very um confusing and an
odd thing and and what's worst of all of
course
is that the doctors don't understand it
either
and at the moment they can try and help
you with your symptoms
um but they don't understand the
underlying physiology which is why it's
so important that
money be raised for research even more
that's being done
now um and and so they can actually
figure it out
i can really tell you struggling for
breath there emma thank you very much
indeed for
for agreeing to do this we can see just
how physically difficult it is for you
but it's very important isn't it to get
this message
out there because people think right
well you've recovered that's
that's covered gone but this is a real
threat to people even
healthy people like you were
i was i mean for a woman of a certain
age i think i was
um and um i mean for example i could do
a plank for six and a half minutes which
apparently is very good
um but i but i yeah so i as soon as i
felt slightly well enough to i i started
working out again
and i think that that had something to
do with why i got long cobit it's just
the theory who knows but
the advice i give to anybody who
contracts covet infection is to rest way
more than
than you think you need to um just keep
resting um and and look after yourself
really really well for much longer than
you imagine you would need and
you know that maybe have something to do
with those of us who are getting
long covered but but nobody knows yeah
rest
what help are you getting you mentioned
obviously the doctors is there a
community though there is a community
has
developed and all kinds of discussions
taking place
right around the country right around
the world about long covert
oh definitely and that's extremely
helpful but we're
a lot of the long-covered um patients in
the uk
are have been waiting with great
anticipation for the opening of
the long covered clinics that have been
talked about along
but first of all some of them haven't
even opened yet
um secondly some of them are calling
themselves postcode which
of course to those of us who are in the
middle of it all it doesn't feel like
it's opposed to anything um and then
also the problem with the
the clinics is is that actually they're
not this great
place to go to where we're all going to
get sorted out that we've been sort of
um waiting for because they haven't got
the funding they haven't got the staff
they haven't got the timing
to have a multi-disciplinary team
of consultants waiting to send us out
for all these really expensive tests
so the clinics are more about rehab and
phys
and physio which we have and physio are
great but they're not necessarily what
we need
one of the strange things about covidis
is that people are having tests like cat
scans and x-rays and blood tests
and then things aren't showing up um
which makes the doctors
um a bit more dismissive of us as than
they might ordinarily be
but then certain doctors are um giving
very advanced tests to patients and
discovering
all sorts of problems with them like for
example
um microclots in the lungs that didn't
show up on a cat
normal cat scan or on a blood test
so so there's lots to learn and until
then
um all of us have to sort of try and try
and be patient really
it's difficult well emma thank you very
much indeed
we and your legions of fans wish you all
the very best please get well soon
thank you thanks emma samsef